สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เป็นอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 9
มีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 11 โมง
11 โมงกี่นาที
ตรง
11 โมง
ตรงนะคะตอนนี้ประเทศไทยก็ 31 องศา
เซลเซียสนะคะ
ร้อนนะคะนักเรียน
ร้อนนะคะแต่ว่า
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าที่พัทยาเนี่ยร้อนไหมคะ
พัทยาเหมือนฝนจะตกเลยค่ะครูหญิง
อ๋อมีเมฆมีแม่มีเมฆมากๆใช่ไหมเหมือนฝนจะ
ตกถ้าฝนจะตกก็ร้อน
ร้อนจริงๆนะคะคุณเคยได้ยินมาเขาบอกว่าคือ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเป็นประเทศร้อนเวลาเราอยู่
ประเทศร้อนเนี่ยใส่เสื้อสีดำเนี่ยไม่โอเค
นะมันจะร้อนมากๆ
จริงหรอแต่ครูฟ้ากับผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อสีดำ
วันนี้นะคะ
ผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าใส่เสื้อสีดำเมื่อก่อน
ตอนนี้ผู้หญิงอะไรคะครูฟ้ามันร้อนหรอ
ก็สีดำใช่ไหมคะแล้วเวลาเราเจอดวงอาทิตย์
มันก็จะร้อนมากๆสีดำสีดำหรือว่าสีน้ำเงิน
อย่างนี้ก็ได้นะสีน้ำเงินเข้มๆอย่างนี้ก็
ร้อนแต่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยใส่เสื้อสี
ดำเพราะว่าไม่ได้ชอบใส่เสื้อสีดำ
ทำไม
ผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นคนชอบกินใช่ไหม
คะเวลาที่กินเนี่ยกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนาะ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนาะมีชามแล้ว
ก็มีน้ำซุปแล้วก็มีเส้นนะคะอาจจะเป็นเส้น
บะหมี่แล้วก็มีตะเกียบใช่ไหมแล้วก็มีลูก
ชิ้นก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนี่ยเวลากินก๋วยเตี๋ยวกิน
กินเนี่ยนะคะถ้าใส่เสื้อสีดำแล้วมีน้ำ
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนี่ยกระเด็นกระเด็นกระเด็นใส่
เสื้อมองไม่เห็น
อ๋อสปาเก็ตตี้ได้ไหม
ได้ค่ะครูฟ้าชอบกินสปาเก็ตตี้ไหม
สปาเก็ตตี้ใช่ไหมแล้วก็มีเส้นสปาเก็ตตี้
สีเหลืองๆ
แล้วก็มีซอสมะเขือเทศสีแดงๆเนี่ยมีซอส
มะเขือเทศนะคะนักเรียนครูฟ้าชอบกินไหมคะ
ซอสมะเขือเทศ
มากค่ะผู้หญิง
จะเล่นยังไงเอาไปใกล้แค่
มันคืออะไร
อันนี้คือมะเขือเทศใช่ไหมนี่คือซอสมะเขือ
เทศนะคะนี่ข้างบนนี้ก็คือสปาเก็ตตี้แล้ว
ก็ซอสมะเขือเทศอ่ะแล้วเราก็จะมีช้อนใช่
ไหมแล้วก็มีส้อม
แล้วก็เอาส้อมเนี่ยวนๆๆบางครั้งเนี่ยซอส
มะเขือเทศเนี่ยมันกระเด็นกระเด็นกระเด็น
กระเด็นกระเด็นใส่เสื้อแบบนี้
กระเด็นใส่เสื้อหรอ
ใช่ค่ะถ้าเราใส่เสื้อสีขาวแบบในรูปนี้
เนี่ยในรูปนี้เนี่ยนะคะเสื้อสีขาวเวลาที่
เรากินพวกซอสมะเขือเทศแล้วซอสเนี่ยมัน
กระเด็นใส่เสื้อเสื้อสีขาวเนี่ยมันมอง
เห็นเลยนะ
อุ้ยผู้หญิงไม่สวยเลยไม่โอเค
ใช่ค่ะแต่ผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยใส่เสื้อ
สีดำมองไม่เห็น
ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้ากินสปาเก็ตตี้โอเคใช่ไหม
โอเคเลยค่ะเวลากระเด็นใส่เสื้อก็
สีดำ
เพราะว่าซอสมะเขือเทศเนี่ยมันสีแดงใช่ไหม
เนี่ยสีแดง
สีแดงอยู่บนสีดำมองไม่เห็นนะคะแต่ถ้าอยู่
บนสีขาวหรืออย่างผู้ชายคนนี้ก็ไม่ได้ใส่
อันนี้ก็ไม่ได้เป็นสีขาวเนาะออกสีเทาๆ
ถ้าซอสหยดอันนี้มันเป็นซอสหยดใส่นะคะเค้า
น่าจะกินฮอทดอกใช่มั้ยแล้วมันก็มีซอสก็
ซอสมะเขือเทศเหมือนกันเนาะ
ใช่ค่ะก็หยดใส่เสื้อหรือว่ามันกระเด็น
สมัยเวลาที่เรากินแล้วอาจจะแบบเยอะใส่
หรือกระเด็นใส่เสื้อของเราครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เวลาครูฟ้ากินสปาเก็ตตี้กินก๋วยเตี๋ยวคน
ไทยจะมีก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่เป็นน้ำซุปสีชมพู
ด้วยนะคะ
น้ำซุปเนี่ยมันจะสีชมพูๆ
เวลาครูฟ้ากินสปาเก็ตตี้กินก๋วยเตี๋ยว
เนี่ยพวกซอสสปาเก็ตตี้ซอสมะเขือเทศหรือ
ว่าน้ำซุปเนี่ยกระเด็นใส่เสื้อไหมโดยปกติ
เวลาครูฟ้ากินอาหารเมื่อวานนี้เลยค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้เมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีน่ะนะ
คะวันพฤหัสบดีที่ 9 นะคะมีนาคมเนี่ยนะคะ
เมื่อวานนี้
ทำไมลูกค้าได้กินซูชิค่ะ
ที่มีข้าวใช่ไหมมีข้าว
แล้วก็มีปลาแซลมอนอยู่ข้างบนอย่างนี้
[เพลง]
มันมีซอสอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ไม่มีโชว์อยู่ไง
ที่เป็นน้ำจิ้มใช่ไหมคะ
ข้างในนี้ก็จะมีซอสโชว์อยู่
แล้วครูฟ้าก็จะมีตะเกียบ
ตะเกียบ
คือตอนแรกที่ครูฟ้ากินเนี่ยนะคะซอสโชยุ
เนี่ยนักเรียนเลยค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะมันอยู่ในซองพลาสติกนะ
คะแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
อันนี้คือซอสมะเขือเทศอยู่ในซองพลาสติก
แต่โชยุของครูฟ้าเนี่ยแปลว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
สั่งแล้วก็เดลิเวอรี่มาส่งที่บ้าน
ใช่ค่ะแล้วมันก็อยู่ในซองพลาสติกแบบนี้นะ
คะ
มันต้องตัดตรงนี้
ใช่ไหม
มันนิดนึงแล้วเขาก็เทใส่ถ้วยใช่ไหมอันนี้
เป็นถ้วยแล้วก็โชยุแล้วก็เทแต่ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยบีบ
มันออกมาให้หมดหรอ
เพราะว่าบีบมากๆซอสเนี่ยมันก็เลย
กระเด็นค่ะนักเรียน
ใส่หน้าหรอ
กระเด็นขึ้นหน้าด้วยนะคะแล้วก็กระเด็นใส่
เสื้อเอ้าแล้วเมื่อวานเนี่ยครูฟ้าใส่
เสื้อสีดำไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าใส่เสื้อสีเหลือง
เหลืองเนี่ย
เสื้อสีเหลืองก็ต้อง
เลอะซอสโชยุสิ
ใช่ค่ะที่เสื้อครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็เลยมีซอสซอสๆ
ๆ
สีน้ำตาล
ใส่เสื้อสีดำจะไม่มีนะ
แล้วครูฟ้าทำยังไงอ่ะคะพอเสื้อครูฟ้า
เนี่ยมีซอสโชว์อยู่เพราะคุณฟ้าเนี่ยใส่
เสื้อสีเหลืองใช่ไหม
เลือกครูฟ้ามันก็จะเหลืองอ่อนๆประมาณนี้
เนาะไม่ได้เหลืองมากขนาดนั้น
แล้วก็มี
มีซอสโชยุ
กระเด็นเลอะครูฟ้าทำยังไงอ่ะคะ
เพราะว่ามันเป็นซอสโชยุเนี่ยมันเป็นน้ำ
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าจะเอาทิชชูเช็ดก็ไม่ได้นะมัน
ไม่ออก
มาก็เลย
ถอดเสื้อนะคะ
ค่ะแล้วก็เอาเสื้อเนี่ย
แล้วก็เปิดน้ำ
แล้วก็เอาเสื้อ
ขยี้ในน้ำ
ครูฟ้าก็เข้าไปในห้องน้ำใช่ไหม
คะนักเรียนแล้วก็ตัวนี้ก็จะมีสิงห์ป่ะ
เนี่ย
แล้วตรงนี้ก็จะมีก๊อกน้ำป่ะ
แล้วก็มีน้ำใช่ไหมครูฟ้าก็เอาเสื้อไปซัก
เลยก็คือครูฟ้าถอดเสื้อแล้วก็เปลี่ยน
เสื้อทำไมเสื้อสีเหลืองตัวนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้า
ไม่ใสแล้ว
[เพลง]
ซื้อได้ที่เลอะโชว์อยู่เนี่ยนะคะแล้วก็
เปิดน้ำแล้วก็เอาเสื้อในไปขยี้นิดหน่อย
นิดหน่อย
แล้วก็
เอาไปซัก
ก็คือขยี้ขยี้ตรงที่เสื้อที่มีเอ่อที่มัน
เลอะซอสโชยุไม่ได้ทั้งหมดทั้งตัวทำไมอ่ะ
คะคุณมาทำไมต้องเปลี่ยนน่ะครูฟ้าก็เสื้อ
มีซอสโชอยู่แล้วก็ครูฟาก็อยู่ที่บ้านโอเค
ไม่ได้ไปช้อปปิ้งไม่ได้ไปออฟฟิศเสื้อเลอะ
โชยุใส่ที่บ้านหรือว่ามีวีดีโอนักเรียนก็
ไม่เห็นนักเรียนเห็นแค่นี้ของครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่เห็นเสื้อนะคะ
แต่มันไม่โอเคนะครูหญิง
ทำไมมันไม่โอเคคะครูฟ้า
มันเหม็นไง
ฟ้าก็จะนั่งสอนภาษาไทยแล้วก็ก็โชยุโชยุ
ที่ไหน
กูไม่ชอบกลิ่นเหม็น
คือโชยุเนี่ยมันโอเคถ้าคุณพระไปดมโชว์
อยู่มันก็หอมแหละแต่ถ้าโชยุมันมาอยู่บน
เสื้อเราเนี่ยเราจะบอกมันเหม็นนะนักเรียน
เพราะว่าเราจะนั่งอยู่ที่นี่ใช่ไหมอันนี้
คือจมูกของเรานะคะแล้วโชยุเนี่ยมันเลอะ
อยู่บนเสื้อเวลาเรานั่งอยู่เนี่ยเราก็จะ
กลิ่นโชยุเนี่ยมันจะลอยขึ้นมาที่จมูกเรา
ก็จะโชว์อยู่เอ้าเสื้อมันตลอดเวลาไงใช่
มั้ยคะครูฟ้าก็เลยเปลี่ยนเสื้อแล้วเนี่ย
เป็นซอสโชว์อยู่จริงๆมันจะเล็กๆใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วซอสมะเขือเทศล่ะแบบเนี้ยเสื้อเลอะซอส
มะเขือเทศแบบนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าเคยไหมคะผู้
หญิงเนี่ยเคยนะ
ผู้หญิง
แต่ซอสมะเขือเทศนะคะมันจะไม่เหมือนซอส
โชยุใช่ไหมซอสมะเขือเทศหรือว่าซอส
บาร์บีคิวเนี่ยเห็นไหมมันจะไม่ได้เป็นน้ำ
100% น่ะมันจะมีความเหมือนครีมๆนิดหน่อย
เวลาที่ซอสแบบนี้ซอสเนี่ยมันหยดลงที่
เสื้อหรือว่ามันกระเด็น
กระเด็นหรือหยดที่เสื้อเนี่ยมันจะมีตรง
นี้อยู่ซึ่งเวลาที่ซ้อนมะเขือเทศแบบนี้นะ
คะนักเรียนมันกระเด็นที่เสื้อเราเนี่ยเรา
จะคิดว่าคนส่วนใหญ่เลยเนี่ยนะคะก็จะเอา
ทิชชู่กระดาษทิชชูซึ่งครูฟ้ามีเยอะอยู่
แล้วไม่ต้องกลัวนะคะนี่ไงทำไมครูฟ้ามี
ทิชชู่ในกระเป๋า
เพื่อซื้อเช็ดหน้าใช่ไหม
เช็ดเสื้อนะคะ
เขาก็จะเอาทิชชู่นะคนไทยนะอันนี้เอาคนไทย
แล้วกันนะคะนักเรียนถ้ามีสอดเลอะถ้าอยู่
ที่บ้านอ่ะมันจะไม่เหมือนกันนะคะนักเรียน
ถ้าครูหญิงอยู่ที่บ้านแล้วกินสปาเก็ตตี้
มีซอสมะเขือเทศเลอะอ่ะผู้หญิงเนี่ย
เปลี่ยนเสื้อเลยไม่ใส่ถอดเสื้อแล้วก็
เปลี่ยนแล้วก็ซักเหมือนครูฟ้า
แต่ถ้าเราไม่ได้อยู่ที่บ้านล่ะคะครูฟ้า
เราไม่ได้มีเสื้อในกระเป๋าใช่ไหม
เราไม่ได้เอาเสื้อไปด้วยหลายๆตัวนะคะ
ถ้าเราอยู่ที่อื่นไม่ใช่ที่บ้าน
ถ้าซอสมะเขือเทศซอสบาร์บีคิวซอสอะไรก็ได้
แล้วเรากินเรากิน KFC กินเฟรนฟรายแล้วมัน
กระเด็น
คิดว่าคนส่วนใหญ่ทำอย่างแรกก็คือหยิบ
ทิชชู่แล้วก็เช็ด
ออกก่อน
เพราะว่าถ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีซอสแบบนี้นะคะ
ผู้หญิงไม่เอาทิชชู่เช็ดแล้วครูฟ้าฮัลโหล
แล้วก็กอดกันก็ฟรี
ผู้หญิง
ก็เลยคิดว่าอะไรคะ
กลับมาหรือยังคะ
ยังคิดว่าอะไรคะผู้หญิงคิดว่าก็คนส่วน
ใหญ่ก็จะเอากระดาษทิชชูหรือว่าทิชชู่
เนี่ยนะคะทิชชู่อาจจะเป็นทิชชู่ธรรมดา
หรือว่าเป็นทิชชู่เปียกที่เป็น White
ทิชชู่ที่มีแอลกอฮอล์มีน้ำนะคะเช็ดใช่ไหม
คะเช็ดออกก่อน Step ที่ 1 ส่วนใหญ่นะ
เพราะว่าเราจะกินเวลาซอสมะเขือเทศเนี่ย
มันจะกระเด็นใส่เสื้อเราก็คือเราต้องกิน
ข้าวกินข้าวเราก็จะอยู่ที่ร้านอาหารร้าน
อาหารทุกร้านเขามีกระดาษทิชชู่ให้เราอยู่
แล้วนะคะเราเอากระดาษทิชชูเนี่ยเช็ดใช่
ไหมคะแต่ถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงเนี่ยผู้หญิงเลอะ
ผู้หญิงก็เอากระดาษทิชชู่เช็ดคุณหญิงก็
โอเคแล้วนะ
ถึงแม้ว่าเสื้อจะเป็นสีขาวผู้หญิงก็ไป
เดินชอบปิ้งไปดูหนังได้
ถ้าเราเอากระดาษทิชชู่เช็ดแล้วเราใช้
สเปรย์แอลกอฮอล์ได้ไหม
ผู้หญิงมีสเปรย์แอลกอฮอล์มั้ย
เรแอลกอฮอล์นะคะนักเรียนคิดว่าตอนนี้ใช่
ไหม
แล้วก็เอากระดาษทิชชู่เช็ดอีก 1 ครั้ง
หรือว่าเรามีกระดาษที่เป็นกระดาษที่มี
แอลกอฮอล์
ไว้ใช่ไหมเราเรียกว่ากระดาษเปียก
ทิชชู่เปียกแบบนั้นก็จะดีกว่านะคะเพราะ
ว่ามันเช็ดออกแล้วมันก็เหมือนซักใช่ไหม
เหมือนซักแต่ถ้าบางคนเขารู้สึกไม่โอเคคือ
เช็ดออกแล้วแต่เสื้อเนี่ยมันก็ยังมีจุดมี
รอยไม่มีรอยแบบนี้คือเส้นออกแล้วมันก็จะ
มีรอยเค้าเรียกอะไรเป็นคราบใช่ไหมเรา
เรียกคราบเนี่ยมีคราบอยู่เพราะว่านี่มัน
คือสีแดง
เราใส่เสื้อสีขาวเนี่ยมันก็ยังมีอยู่คือ
เราจะเปลี่ยนเสื้อได้นะเปลี่ยนได้นะคะถอด
เสื้อได้ก็คือซื้อใหม่
บางคนไม่โอเคก็ไปเดินช็อปปิ้งแล้วก็ซื้อ
ซื้อเสื้อใหม่
ซื้อใหม่ก็โอเคแหละแต่ว่า
ถ้าเกิดเดินอยู่ในที่ที่ไม่มีร้านขาย
เสื้อหลักผู้หญิง
หรือว่าบางคนเนี่ยเสื้อเนี่ยเสื้อที่ซื้อ
มาใช่ไหมซื้อมาเนี่ยต้องซักก่อนแล้วถึงจะ
ใส่เขาก็ไม่โอเคคิดว่าบางคนก็ไปห้องน้ำนะ
ครูฟ้าว่าถ้าเราไปร้านอาหารไปช้อปปิ้ง
Center ไป Supermarket เนี่ยเขาก็จะมี
ห้องน้ำใช่ไหม
มีห้องน้ำก็จะมีกระจกเนี่ยแหละค่ะ
แล้วก็มีซิงค์เนี่ยมีซิงค์แบบนี้เราอาจจะ
ไม่ได้แบบถอดเสื้อออกมาซักอ่ะเราก็อาจจะ
แบบโอเคเปิดแล้วก็ถูใช่มั้ยขยี้
ขยี้นะคะตรงเสื้อของเราที่มันเลอะซอส
สปาเก็ตตี้ก็ได้นะ
ถ้าเป็นครูฟ้านะคะนักเรียน
เสื้อเลอะซอสมะเขือเทศใช่ไหมหรือว่าเสื้อ
เลอะซอสสปาเก็ตตี้เนี่ยฟ้าก็จะไปห้องน้ำ
ก่อนนะคะ
เอาไปซัก
นิดหน่อย
อันนี้ใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
คะว่า
น้ำน่าจะโอเคที่สุดนะ
เพราะว่าบางคนอาจจะแบบว่าไม่ได้คิดว่า
เฮ้ยถ้าเอาทิชชู่เช็ดออกแล้วมันก็ยังมีมี
คราบมีคราบ
ของซอสอยู่แล้วมันก็ยังมีกลิ่นใช่ไหมแต่
ถ้าครูฟ้าไปห้องน้ำเลยเอาน้ำซักออกเนี่ย
มันก็จะสะอาดมากกว่าแต่ว่าบางคนเนี่ยก็
อาจจะไม่ใช้ทิชชู่ก็ได้นะ
ครูฟ้า
อะไรนะคะ
ไม่มีนิ้วค่ะใช้นิ้วของเรา
นิ้วหรอนิ้วโอเคหรอ
โอเคค่ะเอานี่ไงมีซอสเลอะใช่ไหมแบบนี้
เนี่ย
มีซอส
ซอสสปาเก็ตตี้เนี่ยกระเด็นใส่เสื้อเรา
หรือว่าหยดใส่เสื้อเราแบบนี้เราก็เอานิ้ว
เนี่ยปาดเลยค่ะ
แล้วก็กินต่อโอเคมั้ย
กินต่อมั้ยโอเคค่ะกินได้นี่คือเสื้อของ
เราแต่ถ้ามันเลอะที่เสื้อครูฟ้าและผู้
หญิงเอานิ้วไปปาดแล้วกินอันนี้ไม่โอเคแต่
นี่เสื้อครูหญิงไงแต่ว่าไม่เกี่ยวกับกิน
นะคะนักเรียนแต่บางคนเนี่ยก็อาจจะแบบตกใจ
แล้วก็ไม่ได้หาไม่ได้หาว่ามีทิชชู่ไหม
หรือบางคนไม่มีทิชชู่ในกระเป๋า
อย่างผู้ชายผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีกระเป๋าใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยมีกระเป๋าอยู่แล้ว
แต่ผู้ชายถ้าเป็นผู้ชายเนี่ยบางครั้งอาจ
จะไม่มีกระเป๋าหรือผู้ชายไม่มีกระดาษ
ทิชชูไปคนเดียวไม่ได้เป็นผู้ชายแล้วก็ไม่
มีแฟนอย่างเงี้ยอาจจะไม่มีแฟนไปคนเดียวก็
มันเลอะอ่ะทำยังไงล่ะเราก็มีนิ้วไงก็เอา
นิ้วเนี่ยปาดออกแล้วก็เช็ดปากใส่เสื้อครู
ฟ้า
บางคนก็อาจจะใช้นิ้วนะคะใช้นิ้วในการแบบ
เออเอามันออกก่อนจากเสื้อของเราไม่ให้มัน
ติดอยู่บนเสื้อของเรานานๆอันนี้มันซักซัก
ยากนะคะก็เอานิ้วเนี่ยปาดออกก่อนแล้วทำ
ยังไงต่อ
ก็บอกว่าเออขอโทษนะคะมีทิชชู่ไหม
ห้องน้ำมีทุกอย่างห้องน้ำมีโชคน้ำมีน้ำ
เพราะฉะนั้นนะคะนักเรียนอาจจะใช้วิธีของ
ครูฟ้าก็ได้ก็คือถ้ามีซอสมีโชยุมีอะไรก็
ตามหรือว่านักเรียนดื่มกาแฟแล้วมันหกเลอะ
เสื้อไปห้องน้ำค่ะห้องน้ำที่ประเทศไทยมี
ทุกอย่างเนาะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะถ้านัก
เรียนกินอาหารแล้วมันมีซอสเนี่ยกระเด็น
ใส่เสื้อนักเรียนทำยังไงไปห้องน้ำเหมือน
ครูฟ้าเอาทิชชู่เช็ดหรือว่าใช้นิ้วเช็ดก็
comment บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้
เนี่ยครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเรา
เจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะ